anthony blinken had strong words for the
rwandan government after u.n experts
said they have evidence rwanda is
backing m23 rebels in neighboring
democratic republic of congo
we recognize that rwanda has security
concerns of its own including reports of
cooperation between the congolese
military and the democratic forces for
the liberation of rwanda the dflr
an armed group
my message to both president chi
sechetti and president kagame this week
has been the same
any support or cooperation with any
armed group in eastern drc
endangers local communities and regional
stability
rwanda's government denies allegations
it supports m23
rwanda is not the cause of long-standing
stability in eastern drc
where we have over 130 armed groups
including the m23
and the presence of the fdlr and the
close collaboration
with the army of the drc
has always been the most significant
cause of insecurity
the congolese government and rwanda have
had years of tension with both sides
accusing each other of funding
rebellions
since may the armed group calling itself
m23 has weighed its most sustained
offensive in years killing dozens and
displacing tens of thousands of people
we were displaced after m23 captured our
village we are afraid of them when they
are fighting they do not differentiate
between soldiers and civilians we do not
want to die here
lincoln also discussed the jailing of
paul through cesar barghina the man
portrayed in the film hotel rwanda
sheltering hundreds of people during the
1994 genocide rusesavagina a u.s
permanent resident was sentenced last
september to 25 years in prison after
being convicted of terrorism charges
tied to an organization opposed to
president por gagami's leadership
as far as government of rwanda is
concerned
purusa sawajina is a london citizen and
he was arrested he was tried
and convicted
along with 20
others
20 other accomplices
for serious crimes they committed
against rwandan citizens
and
which he committed while residing in the
united states
before his trip to east africa lincoln
was in south africa analysts say the u.s
wants to increase its diplomacy in the
region to counter russia's growing
influence on the african continent haru
mutasa al jazeera